so as we told you many times before
as soon as the economy crashed to the
benefit of the big banks the new york
times washington post etc etc started
throwing the word racist around with
increasing volume it was almost like
they were working on behalf of the
oligarchs to divide the rest of us
against each other so we wouldn't notice
that a small group is getting super
super rich
almost nobody in journalism ever
mentions this bacia angar sargon is one
of the few who does she just went on
seeing over the week we feel guilty
playing a clip from a rival network but
this is just too good to miss here's how
it went
the media's response to junkin's victory
is literally the reason that he won
right how did they respond there's a
hundred media has a hundred percent
reactions you're pretty pretty overly
generalized and i think let me get more
specific for you okay because i have to
say i have to admit having watched cnn
all week there's been a lot of very very
very good genuflection on this front um
but what happened right after the
election was you saw host after host
after host on msnbc saying oh this is a
victory for white supremacy right white
supremacy wins again racism wins again
when you know the lieutenant governor
that youngkin won with will be the first
black woman to hold that job when glenn
younkin managed to flip majority black
districts
but younger sargon is the deputy opinion
editor at newsweek also authored the new
book bad news how woke media is
undermining democracy she joins us
tonight thanks so much for coming on i'm
sorry to embarrass you with that clip oh
my gosh tucker thank you so much for
having me oh of course so
so you say it's undermining democracy
what i think is interesting about your
take on it is you take it to i think a
deeper level it's more than just
annoying there's a purpose to all this
what do you think the purpose is
well i think you really nailed it in
your opening tucker you know you started
out by saying that we have this deep
class divide in america that separates
the people who are really feeling you
know the inflation at the gas pump from
the people who live in you know coastal
cities who maybe don't drive maybe they
take ubers maybe they take the subway
and the history of journalism in the
20th century in america is the history
of a class of people moving from one of
those classes to the other right
journalism used to be a working-class
trade and throughout the 20th century
journalists became part of the american
elites and as they did so they abandoned
the working class of all races and what
we're seeing now with woke media is just
the latest stage of that abandonment
well i mean that's i've seen it in i've
seen it up close i think you're exactly
right the composition of newsrooms is
completely different but that's a
perversion of the core mission of
journalism we always heard when i was a
30 years ago when i started you know
it's to afflict the comfortable and
comfort the afflicted to hold the
powerful to account you know be the eyes
and ears of your readers and viewers
like it does seem like they're a
praetorian guard for the billionaire
class i'm sorry to overstate it but it
feels that way
yeah you really see a lot of class
solidarity right now among liberal
elites and i'm saying this as a lefty
tucker i'm coming at this from the left
and feeling like how did we abandon the
working class again of all races how did
we become the side that comforts the
comfortable and afflicts the afflicted
so where does this go i mean we need a
working media we need a media people
trust it's an essential ingredient in
democracy i think everyone agrees with
that no one trusts the media anymore so
what's the next phase in this evolution
do you think
honestly tucker i think that every
american has to relearn
the the work of learning to respect
people that we disagree with you're
seeing a huge consumer boycott of
mainstream media of corporate media and
i think that's a good thing they need to
re-learn how to get our trust back and
in the meantime we need to start
stitching back together the fabric of
american society by respecting people we
disagree with that's all we can do
i just have to ask since you are on the
left and i think you're articulating
traditional left-wing concerns about
economics
what do people on your side think of
what you're saying right now
you know honestly you know the fact that
i was on cnn i take that as a really
good sign my book opens with a scene
from cnn of two of their hosts who are
both millionaires calling every single
person who voted for donald trump racist
when we know that donald trump won the
vast majority of people without a
college degree right and to me that was
this primal scene of these people who
had won by every metric sneering and
smearing the people who had lost right
and so i think it's a really good sign
that cnn had me on to talk about my work
god that's i i don't i could not have
put it as well as you just did i
appreciate your coming on tonight boccia
thank you very much thank you tucker
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else